c'est une rentrée à hauts risques pour
jean castex pourtant très présent sur le
terrain cet été avec 16 déplacements
rien qu'en juillet le nouveau premier
ministre est rattrapée par les effets de
la crise sanitaire
selon le dernier baromètre ifop pour le
jdd il ne recueille que 48% d'opinions
favorables une baisse de 7 points par
rapport à début juillet dans le même
temps 46% des personnes interrogées le
désapprouvent aujourd'hui un chiffre en
hausse
emmanuel macron lui a fixé son cap pour
la rentrée vivre avec le virus mais sans
mettre le pays à l'arrêt autrement dit
sans affaiblir davantage l'économie
mardi le chef de l'état a prévu un
conseil de défense pour faire le point
sur l'évolution de l'épidémie et sur sa
gestion
les mesures de précaution sanitaires
dans les établissements scolaires les
entreprises et les transports en
particulier au centre de toutes les
attentions devrait être annoncé à la
sortie du premier conseil des ministres
de rentrée mercredi la question du port
du masque obligatoire dans les collèges
les lycées et les entreprises à compter
du 1er septembre et déjà l'occasion pour
le monde politique de prendre position
avec en ligne de mire la présidentielle
de 2022
[Musique]
pour nombre d'observateurs cette rentrée
2020 exceptionnel du fait de la crise
sanitaire fera figure de test pour les
deux dernières années du quinquennat